carton à vider et beaucoup d'articles à
mettre en rayon impossible de rater
cette fin d'année saison capitale pour
les commerçants il ya un côté de ce
triste quand c'est pas du tout commence
il y aura du monde si on au contraire il
ya énormément de monde vraiment c'est on
est un peu tous en discutant avec les
autres commerçants est tous un peu
perturbé on ne sait pas à quelle sauce
on va être mangés en feu en face la
voisine peaufine la vitrine pense que ça
peut être bien on fait le côté là
argenté puis là on fait un petit peu
plus dorée et là aussi la perspective de
noël rassure c'est vrai que l'on a envie
de mettre de la lumière de la gaieté
d'accueillir vraiment notre clientèle du
mieux dans la bienveillance dernière
livraison dans sept autres boutiques
franchisées celle ci est donc opération
déballage pour les deux vendeuses nous
ont fait parvenir beaucoup de
marchandises on a eu dix neuf cartons
donc ça représente à peu près de 1000
pièces à mettre en rayon
donc il faut que pour samedi tout soit
en rayons tout soit rangé la boutique
propre qui mise aux normes du coup avec
les nouveaux protocoles philips
s'apprête aussi à ouvrir sauf qu'un mois
de confinement a laissé des traces
il a la moitié de son stock en trop
alors ce week-end pas le choix il faut
brader ses des vêtements d'hiver qui
sera impossible de vendre printemps et
de toute façon on doit vendre notre
stock
on doit le faire sortir coûte que coûte
je dirais coûte que coûte ça veut dire
en faisant des prix s'il faut pour
pouvoir rentrer les nouvelles
collections à venir printemps été qui
arrive en général à partir de janvier
l'impatience grandit et même si la porte
est déjà ouverte
il faudra tout de même attendre jusqu'à
samedi